reject nation what is going on greg here today
so right now it is about four o'clock in the
morning i cannot sleep because i am way too
anxious about fighting for my dead center seats
for imax for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so i just gotta wait till they go on sale
but my buddy paul from heavy spoilers go check
out his moon night episode 2 breakdown by the
way he's telling me that there's a special
trailer that's supposed to go on youtube and
i'm going to wait to upload this one when
that's officially up on youtube but it's
it's already a pre-roll and that pre-roll's
already on twitter so i'm just going to watch
it right now since i got nothing else to do
so thank you paul for giving me a heads up if
you guys haven't seen our moonette episode
2 reaction you can check that out by the
way too after this video but yeah if you could
leave a like i would very much appreciate that
subscribe and click that notification bell to get
notified when our review for doctor strange two
is up on the channel all right enough chit
chat let's see what's in this special look
all right it's 30 seconds long it's probably gonna
watch it twice i've been dreaming the same dream
oh every morning the same tommy night
where nightmare okay of the multiverse
depends on us
oh [ __ ] you got the third eye
doctor screen to the multiverse of madness
tickets on sale now they're on sale now for
me i mean they probably are by the time this
video is live let's watch that again oh yes you
taught me a bill i chose the right shirt for
this video i've been dreaming the same dream
amy nightmare is the villain of the multiverse
of sexy about sinister strange with that third
eye i don't know what's doing it for me but
it's doing it it's happening all right guys
well i feel like there is some good stuff in
here to talk about for sure i want to know what
your guys's theories are down below and what the
hell you think is going on show your know-it-all
comments down below as we were kicking this off
the the first that stands out to me actually is
what's being said at the very top when dr strange
is saying i've been dreaming and then it overlaps
into what wanda is saying i've been dreaming the
same dream and every morning the same nightmare
it's interesting how you put it into the certain
context because it looks like in other trailers
at least that dr strange himself is probably
experiencing things that feel like dreams
maybe premonitions or maybe he's living
out the memories or experiences of some of his
variants or a particular variant and that's what
feels like a nightmare but it feels so real and
here when it's overlapping into wanda when she's
been saying i've been dreaming the same dream
it seems like her dream is her being able to be
wanda and have her children have her family tommy
and billy and then she wakes up and that dream is
not a reality so her her living circumstances are
the nightmare the fact that she doesn't have that
dream attained is what equals the nightmare
however we did see in the other trailer the
official second trailer she does interact with
whomever that wanda variant is the wanda that
was able to have a family from what i'm able to
gather at least from the way they're slicing the
trailer together you know marvel they're really
good at misleading us but maybe they're really
clueing us in this time i imagine the ways
how some of this plot might actually progress
is that at first the scarlet witch that we're
following are wanda maximoff she's experiencing
this dream but really she's experienced it through
the lens of one of her variants so she wants to be
able to sort of attain that you know i've heard
many theories of her traversing the multiverse
and maybe she wants to take over this wanda's
life so she can have the kids and have the family
somehow they'll be like slammed together the two
of them for a bunch of theories who knows what's
actually going to be true regardless what
i think this trailer is really clueing us
in on is the fact that there is a wanda variant
out there who has the family she's able to like i
don't know if it's like astral projection or she's
taking over the body and in whatever these dreams
are that variant is very much real she's probably
going to be seeking out this dream to turn it into
a reality of sorts what i really loved about
this trailer though is they really amped up the
scarlet witch as the main villain one of her lines
there you hear her russian accent bleeding through
right where and it's funny because when you look
at one division they did kind of poke fun at it
you did have you know pietro ralph boner at one
point did say like what happened to your accent
you know they do poke fun at the fact that her
voice went from like russian to american in
the show it seemed intentional to the point where
it's when she's like you know being a badass when
she's being threatening that's when the russian
girl comes through that's when the sokopia girl
really comes through so she seemed quite menacing
in this trailer and i was eating it up i really
loved it a lot and i also want to put this out for
those who watched our reaction to the tv spot the
other day uh that footage of what a lot of people
ourselves included were thinking like it could be
catholic i was watching you rockstar's video
yesterday and they were pointing out how there
was this other demon on the bottom right and ifos
was theorizing it could be i wanna say and gyra i
don't know how to pronounce it all right they're
basically elder spawn demons that are created by
catholics so at least you would get some sort of
connection to k'thon there but i do believe what
everyone has to arrive at this that sequence
there there within the darkhold temple itself
the darkhold of course as established in the one
division series which will be a major factor into
the whole adventure going on here and then
of course what a lot of people call sinister
strange i don't know if that's the technical term
for him but sinister strange having a third eye i
mean he probably has more types of psychic powers
but i'm gonna ask for you like super avid doctor
strange comic book readers because full disclosure
i mean i have the marvel unlimited app and i catch
up on so many comics over there but i've only
recently been diving into doctor strange comics
in preparation for multiverse and madness so when
it comes to properly theorizing what the third
eye could actually entail you know the third eye
is not something you know invented by the doctor
strange comics or some philosophical beliefs that
the third eye can see time that there could be
other spiritual dimensional links that basically
allow you to really see truth and it makes me
wonder if like at some point our doctor strange
is going to awaken his third eye as well either
way that makes him a lot more intimidating in that
specific scene and i'm curious to see ultimately
what will become of that you guys tell me you
tell me i'm not super confident in theorizing
on that specific point but you guys tell me but
anyway people what did you think about this tease
i thought it was awesome leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button check out our moon night episode 2
reaction and last but not least i want to do a p
tyler hague i'm shouting you out right now
because if i were to theorize who might be
awake just doing fun stuff at this hour it'd
be you so right now tyler if you're catching
this shout out i want you to message me and i will
message you back right away tyler you've been part
of our patreon page for so long i can't imagine it
without you i would feel like a part of my heart
has left i'd want to astral project myself into a
variant where i could then be with you permanently
you are the teddy bear of our patreon page one of
the sweetest people i've ever known seriously and
uh just want to be here personally to tell you
thank you screw it i'm just going to message
you myself tyler i'm shouting you out in a in a
youtube video right now i love you buddy you rock